i am so excited to have the one and only
you know where is cameron diaz i know
her as auntie poo poo
um and she's co-hosting uh the entire
bestie hour because we're besties and
tell them about everybody in the
audience and everybody in the audience
here are also all besties which is so
much fun
and um our next guests actually they
reached out to us and they said they
hadn't seen
each other in over two years and well
because this is the bestie hour we were
like we need to reunite them
my name is angela and i would absolutely
love to be reunited with my best friend
jackie we've been best friends ever
since the 7th grade which is 18 years
ago now which is absolutely crazy to me
and we just love each other so much
we've been there for each other
throughout all of our major life events
but we have not been able to see each
other at all throughout the past year
because of covid so we are both very
much looking forward to the day that we
can be reunited and it would be even
more special if it was able to be on
your show because we are both huge fans
of yours please welcome angela
angela welcome
thank you so much
the pandemic wasn't the only thing that
kept you from jackie um is there another
reason that you haven't seen her yeah so
throughout um a pretty good portion of
the pandemic jackie has been pregnant oh
wow that's so
which of course is so exciting when it's
your best friend being pregnant however
that also kind of gave me a reason to
not want to see her just because you
know don't want to chance anything with
kovacs yeah yeah and um we were actually
supposed to see each other a few months
ago for her baby shower
but unfortunately it ended up needing to
be canceled because she was hospitalized
and she ended up delivering her daughter
like three months early what i know it
was so scary god but thankfully now it's
months later and she is at home and
healthy and the baby is beautiful and
her name is vivian
but i still haven't gotten to meet her
and i haven't been able to hug my best
friend yet and it's been really really
hard not having that
i understand
well guess what the wait is finally over
are you ready to reunite with jackie
[Applause]
congratulations by the way thank you
[Music]
you know as if being pregnant isn't
scary enough let's just throw a pandemic
on top of it and then a premature birth
how did covet i did have covert as well
and you did have code yeah while i was
pregnant oh my god oh my gosh
twice what yeah
okay
uh
superwoman i was just you took the words
right out of my mouth
what
uh what's your advice on keeping a cool
head on your shoulders and being strong
and surviving through so many things
that could take people down with fear
uh i'm a lot of support family i have my
family on the next block and she was
amazing with keeping in touch with me
even though we couldn't be face to face
but she would check in on me every
single monday was like our thing and she
would
how are you doing what's going on and
that was kind of what kept me together
during that time for sure
so do you feel comfortable um with her
being able to meet your baby yeah i do
thank gosh because um
uh your um baby is here and you're going
to get to meet her
angela and jackie that's right after
this segment you are gonna go and meet
this little bundle of joy goodness as
we've been so fortunate to do hand each
other our babies
so i'm so excited for this moment for
you not only to reunite but for you to
meet
the most important person now
in your little tribe
so i'm so excited for you both
to get to do that together
all right well angela and jackie um
congratulations on everything
that you conquered and we're so glad to
bring you back together
[Music]